factor out the greatest common factor so
let's write each of these terms and then
factor them out so i could write four
let me color code it four x to the
fourth
x to the fourth y
is going to be equal to i could do the
prime factorization on the 4 that's just
the same thing as 2 times 2
x to the fourth is just x multiplied by
itself 4 times
x times x times x times x and then
finally i have a y
i have the y
and then if i want to do eight if i were
to do eight x to the third y that is
eight
x to the third
x to the third power
and y
once again i could do the prime
factorization of 8 which is 2 times 2
times
2
times 2 x to the third is
x multiplied by itself 3 times x times x
times x and then times
times y
and so the greatest common factor here
is going to be made up
of the largest common factors of these
two things so for example both of these
two characters have two twos in them so
let's put two twos in our greatest
common factor both of them have two twos
so we could have let me write the gcf
so our greatest common factor
our greatest common factor is going to
have two twos in it
that's those two twos right over there
and then
both of these have at least three x's so
our greatest common factor can have
three x's
3i when i say 3x's i should say x to the
third x multiplied by itself
three times
so it's going to be times x times x
times x and then we also have a y in
both of them both of these things are
divisible by y so our greatest common
factor is going to be divisible
by y
and so our greatest common factor is
going to be 2 times 2 times x times x
times x times y which is the same thing
as four
x to the third
four x to the third and we're doing the
right colors here
so this
right over here is four
this is x to the third
that's close enough to blue x to the
third and then we have y
so what what is 4x to the fourth y
well everything i've already boxed off
is 4x to the third y that's the greatest
common factor and so this 4x to the 4th
y is going to be the greatest common
factor times what's left over so if i
were to rewrite this
this first term is going to be 4
4 x to the third power
y
y let me put that in parentheses
and so this takes up all of the factors
except for this last x right over here
except for this let me do this in a
color i haven't used yet except for this
last x right over here and so that's
going to be that x and you can verify if
you multiply this x times this thing
right over here you'd get 4x to the
fourth y
now let's add to that
let's add to that 8x to the third y but
let's rewrite it as a product of its
greatest comp of the greatest common
factor between these two terms and
whatever is left over so the greatest
common factor once again is
four x to the third y
it is four x to the third
x to the third
y
four x to the third y and if i i already
wrote down four x to the third y so that
takes care of all of the things that
i've already boxed off here and all we
have left is this 2 that is not taken
into account by the greatest common
factor so i'm going to write the 2
right over there
and then
we can essentially see we have two terms
both of these terms have the greatest
common factor in it that's actually kind
of by definition this is the largest
factor that factor that goes into both
of these and we talk about largest
factor we're actually just talking about
it has the largest it has the largest
it shares the most factors between these
two terms right over here but with that
out of the way we can essentially
undistribute it or factor it out
factoring out is essentially the
opposite of the distributive property so
we can take or it's the other way of
applying it so we can factor
we can factor the 4x to the third y out
when you factor it out you're left with
an x
plus 2 and we have factored out we have
factored out the 4
x to the third
y and we're done